>>SO MEDIAPABLE OF THEE
OF DEMOCRACY AND CHANGING ITS
SHAPE FOR DESPT
HEORERE
ENABLING DN AND RE
CO PLATFORMS
BOR YOUTUBALSO DOING SOMETHING .
IS JONATHAN HPSE
STERN SCHOOL ONDE TOMAAVE BEENI
TEL OF WN INTHINKS
HOW D,ADAC
E AS A COLLEGE I HEE
E 1995.
LO AANSEEMED
IN TC OF THE
BUT IT2016 THIS BE SUG ON CAMPUS
MANY PEOPLE WERE SAYING .
S EXACTT IT
INTIMITHERS,AKONHEY SAY AND THA
TING DARTS.WHN
ES A LOT AIN AS UR PREVIOUS
GUEST WASACHGE NEWS
MESI TV,S HE
INFORMN AS W MOS HI JOURNALTS
FO
BUT SOMETHING REALLY CHANGEDWHEA
PEOPLE IWA THAWA'TT  SPREADINGOL
PORFOPBUT THERE'S THOR
OF DAY, WHENORD
YOU STAF
ALTHOUGH THE SOCIAL ME GUN S
ANT
WAO SHOOT ANYBOD OPLE LOVITHOOT
ND
BARACK OSHARING IT.
'S A ED
THGOING TO LOOK BACK, IT'S LIK
E MOBER BAGS.
MAGE WE L UESOMEN HINDSIGHHAT'RE
IN THELD?HA
UNDERSTATEMENT.
TELEPHONE, SOMOD Y
ANMITED,G
GREAT, WY
LLTAIT.
THENTURNS OUFEYEAR
FOER LIKESRT SHIPS ANN  MADE ERS
MANY PEOPL
>> THEY WE FEELING ODISCOVAND
NOW IT'SRIBLE. COUNTERARGUMENT
FACEBOOK P RESPOND
CAUSDI ATHEAN  C
LIUPHEAVYOUR>>URE.FIRST, THE MAL
MAINSTREAM T .
THAT THE MAI, ITS,.T'
YOU DO IF YOU ND YOU SAY OUR CA
NDITIONEY ATS OMRESEARCHHEABOU E
MPCA
RESEARCH IS IT'S HARMFUL TO MAN.
SAACQUITE  THREE AND
US.  SO YOICLEE  TO
ANTIC.U MI
Y YOU WERE TELLING. >> ANDN YOL
VEOPE.OUAVR US?
>> YI DO.
I WHEN I WAS WRITING THIS CATHE.
AFTER PUBLISARTICLE, ER, S , NOR
ME BECAUSE TDLE 80% OF THE
COUNXH CLED JOTY
RNG UP.DEMOCRACY HAE RUN BY
TE ATHERS T
BENDING A T
CO
COMPANIES  T
PRODUCT TO BRING OTHER P